hi i'm kristen goodwin on this episode
of the fox news rundown
president trump announcing he helped
forge what he calls a historic
agreement between israel and the united
arab emirates to normalize diplomatic
relations
what is the significance and will it
bring us closer to peace in the middle
east
president of eurasia group ian bremmer
shares his insights on what this could
mean for the region
and details why he refers to this deal
as an obvious win
for the u.s and the latest fox news poll
continues to show president trump
trailing presumptive democratic nominee
joe biden but will biden's lead
last fox news sunday host chris wallace
weighs in
he'll also discuss congress stalling on
a coronavirus stimulus package
and the commander-in-chief's ongoing
issue with mail-in voting
plus commentary from guy benson host of
the guy benson show
the fox news rundown is a daily news
podcast where we
take a deeper look at the stories
important to you you can subscribe
on your favorite podcast player by going
to foxnewspodcast.com
i'm brian kilmeade i'm martha mccallum
i'm david asman and this is the fox news
rundown
friday august 14 2020 i'm jessica
rosenthal
is it one step closer to actual peace in
the middle east
or is it a one-off deal with one gulf
nation the middle east the most
dysfunctional region geopolitically in
the world
we now see a trend in the opposite
direction how can that not be a way
i'm lisa brady as the nation counts down
to election day
what impact will the coronavirus have at
the ballot box to a certain degree this
is going to be a referendum on donald
trump
how did he handle the coronavirus how
did he handle the economy
and i'm guy benson i've got the final
word on the fox news rundown
just how big a deal is this deal this is
the first time in 20
25 years that israel and an arab country
have normalized diplomatic relations and
entered into a peace deal that's
national security adviser robert o'brien
speaking alongside a number of officials
in the oval office on thursday
surrounding president trump who was
thrilled about israel's new bilateral
agreement
with the united arab emirates we are
already discussing this with
other nations very powerful very
good nations and people that want to see
peace in the middle east
the outgoing u.s special envoy to iran
brian hook explained
peace between the arabs and the israelis
is iran's worst nightmare
and no one has done more to intensify
the conflict
between arabs and israelis than iran and
what we see today is a new middle east
the trend lines are very different today
he said the future is in the gulf with
israel that iran
is in the past the man in front of the
negotiations president trump's
son-in-law jared kushner
explained in broad terms how he thinks
this came about
the president like with all things urged
us to take an untraditional approach
you can't solve problems that have gone
unsolved by doing it the same way that
people before you have tried and failed
the president takes untraditional
approaches he does things in different
ways
but he uses common sense and he tries to
unite people
by focusing on common interests as
opposed to allowing them to focus on
their common grievances
reaction poured in the leaders of
countries with peace agreements with
israel
egypt and jordan praised the deal but
specifically
because it stops for now israeli
settlement building in the west bank
which you'd think the palestinians would
be happy about but they were not
hamas called the deal a backstab saudi
arabian ally
bahrain praised the deal this is the
beginning of normalization of relations
between
israel and the gulf states it is a major
breakthrough
ian bremmer is the president of the
eurasia group and it comes on the back
of so many years of so many people
writing op-eds saying if there wasn't a
peace deal between israel and palestine
that we would never have a future for
this country and actually israel is in a
much stronger position
today than they have been historically
despite the fact that the main efforts
of democratic and republican
administrations for decades
on the palestinian issue has come to
nothing uh but
but israel is is actually a meaningful
ally of the united states and today
is feeling like uh if they are an
increasingly solid geopolitical position
in the region
the trump administration namely the
president himself has said he expects
more bilateral agreements between israel
and other gulf nation countries
uh on the heels of this one and i'm
wondering is this the new
way forward in terms of of middle east
peace in other words we no longer as you
sort of referenced
are doing this setup of okay israelis
talk to palestinians now instead we're
going to go
out to other gulf nations yeah i mean as
you know the
palestinian peace plan that was unveiled
by jared and company
hadn't even involved the palestinians in
writing it up
um when i go and talk to arabs in the
gulf whether it's emiratis or saudis or
bahrainis or kuwaitis or qataris
and i asked them what are the things
that worried them the most in the region
israel palestine isn't even on the list
it's al qaeda
and it's iran it's yemen it's syria it's
libya
um it's the future of the global energy
environment when we're moving away from
fossil fuels it's
it's domestic governance and and frankly
israel is no longer that kind of a
problem in fact they're potentially a
help because they need
israeli technology they need israeli
surveillance they need you know the
ability to diversify their own economies
and
i'm not surprised that the emirates
moved first because
they're the country in the region that
is most oriented towards the 21st
century
and is most diversified away from their
own energy production so
they're diversifying their geopolitics
now too but i i
completely believe that in the coming
months there will be other countries in
the region that will join this is not
going to be a one-off for the uae
the line out of the white house is that
you know i think it came from brian hook
that
you know this these kinds of deals
are iran's worst nightmare how much
are these potential alliances about iran
and what exactly is iran doing to push
gulf countries toward israel
well iran's in a lot of trouble uh
they're they're
a kleptocracy themselves uh they're
they're
increasingly uh with an unhappy
population
their economy has shrunk by 10 in the
last year on the back of u.s sanctions
and now they've got a badly managed
pandemic as well
you remember back in january when we
assassinated
qasim suleimani the head of their
military and they were unable to do
anything but basically wave a white flag
uh you know and and the the proxies that
they have in the region i mean lebanon
hezbollah
i mean given the disaster that's
befallen beirut in the last week that's
not going well either
and now they see the israelis and the
emiratis two of their top enemies in the
region are making peace
and none of this is good for iran at all
and very interestingly
you may not have seen but vice president
biden
just came out with a statement where he
was nothing but supportive i mean you
know in in a hyper politicized
election it is obvious to everyone
this is a win for the united states
there was no need
to criticize this for politics biden was
quite smart and not doing so
everyone should come together and
recognize this is a good thing
let's talk about briefly the winds right
because
you you see the quotes from people about
what this deal means
for example israel says okay travel back
and forth from tel aviv to uae
more muslims coming to see the al-aqsa
mosque we
israelis agree to suspend and delay
any sort of planned annexation or
sovereignty over parts of
judea and samaria namely you can imagine
in the west bank
and settlement expansion right so when
we think of of
wins losses concessions what are they
and and do they how do they matter to to
us in the united states
i mean the israelis are making no
concessions here i mean the fact that
they're holding off on annexation it was
something that six months ago they
weren't doing
um the fact that now you'd be able i
mean the uae is the most technologically
advanced
of gulf countries they'll not just be
traveling they'll be investing
they'll be trading they'll be doing
business i mean
the biggest problem in the middle east
is the fact that you have a whole bunch
of countries that hate each other if
this
is what actually unlocks economic
relations
educational relations cultural relations
between countries that had considered
themselves deep
enemies before that's obviously a win i
mean
when we look around the world right now
we see the united states and china
fighting we see decoupling is what we're
talking about people less economically
integrated
the middle east the most dysfunctional
region geopolitically in the world
we now see a trend in the opposite
direction how can that not be a win
and ian finally um palestinians are less
than pleased we've seen statements from
hamas and fatah
uh they're infuriated really uh
what what do you expect to come from
this
is the is there any country in your mind
that could bring the palestinians
on board in in future talks and future
bilateral agreements or whatever
look i mean the deal that they're being
offered on the table is
less than they got from clinton um
it's less land it's less desirable land
uh though there's money attached to it
um
it's less autonomy and i mean anyone
objectively that looks at that deal
would say well why should i take this i
was being offered something else
20 years ago and the answer is well um
because
you're in a much worse position now and
people don't care about you and
that that the natural human response
that is to be angry
but when you see that actually israel is
not falling apart in fact they're moving
on with their lives and meanwhile
palestinians are starving and they have
no educational opportunities
i mean i don't have any illusions that
hamas
it would be able to would go back to the
table
but maybe the palestinians could get rid
of some of the worst
people that are representing them and
and will vote in
new governments that would be willing to
engage
even if the outcome is suboptimal many
in israel were not surprised things had
been moving in this direction but
as we just talked about with ian bremmer
how do things move forward if
palestinians are not on board
we talked to dr near bombs research
fellow at the moshe dayan center at tel
aviv university
every peace deal in the middle east is
important it is a big deal
this in some ways
has been coming we have seen the designs
for this
the reproachment between the two
countries in many ways some have
observed that if it correctly that we
had
degrees of normalization with the uae
and with the gulf
without the peace process while with
countries like egypt and jordan we had
peace without normalization
so this is very positive it certainly is
a big deal because it will allow
for other things to move it could be
that the uae
uae will be the first and a number of
other countries will follow
but dr the palestinians are not on board
i mean the statements from
from hamas and fatah they
feel uh very strongly this is not in
their favor
even with the agreement from israel to
suspend or delay
annexation of land in in the west bank
what do you make of their reaction not
entirely surprising when uae had landed
a a plane in ben gurion airport full of
aid to the palestinians the palestinians
the pa in that sense chose not to accept
it
partially because it came from uae and
partially because they are
still sticking to an anti-normalization
line
and saying that the only way uh to to
move is to
not to speak with israel rather than to
engage with israel because they think
they have no partner
and in many ways prove to israel that
there is no partner on the other side
so the palestinians stick with this
particular line well the uae is saying
look you know with all the respect
all the respect to the palestinians we
need to move forward that's part of the
message
another part of the message important
enough is saying that the palestinians
are a part of this
if the palestinian will choose to
jump on the bandwagon and jump on the
train it can move with them
if the palestinian will choose not to
and choose to continue with the
anti-normalization line
there's a good chance that the train
will continue to move without them
they're not entirely happy they thought
that they tried to say to the world that
the only way that
the middle east can move and that peace
can happen is if
israel will do you know create work on
the palestinian problem the palestinians
are the key for everything else i think
this move shows
that that may not be the case do you
have any nervousness at the idea of
free travel between uae and and tel aviv
so that
muslims can go pray at al-aqsa
no i i i do not have such fear first of
all there are ways to
make arrangements and screen who is
coming
and who is going second we've had plenty
of guests
i hosted personally a number of people
from
some of these countries a number of
people with from countries with whom the
israelis do not share diplomatic
relations
and and this is something that i think
will only happen
more and more i think the idea of
muslims coming to pray in alexa
can potentially help make al-aqsa what
it should be
one of the most important holy places to
the muslims not just to the palestinians
and i think some of these perspectives
may again bring some fresh ideas onto
the table
of how do we solve the disputes that we
have in the region
dr near bombs thank you so much for your
time you're more than welcome happy to
be here
[Music]
this is guy benson with your fox news
commentary coming up
president trump comes out swinging after
his democratic challenger calls for a
nationwide
mask mandate he wants to shut down our
economy close our schools and grind
society to a halt
and he wants it done by a federal decree
what joe biden said was that every
governor
should mandate mask wearing every single
american
should be wearing a mask when they're
outside
for the next three months at a minimum
speaking after a thursday briefing from
health and economic officials
the first one of his regular virtual
briefings also attended by running mate
kamala harris
that's what real leadership looks like
we just witnessed real leadership
the president accuses the presumptive
democratic nominee
of disregarding the different
circumstances in different states
biden's approach is regressive it's
anti-scientific and
it's very defeatist but it'll be very
bad for our country
and politicizing the virus well
joe biden has been playing politics from
the sidelines he has no clue
in a new fox news poll 85 percent of
voters remain concerned about the virus
spreading more than half think the
government's response
wasn't serious enough and on the virus
and several other major
issues they trust joe biden to do a
better job
by double digits giving president trump
a three-point edge on the economy
overall biden has a seven-point national
lead in the fox news poll
slightly lower than july's eight-point
advantage and down from a 12-point
spread in june
the poll was taken this week but it's
too soon to gauge the impact of senator
harris as biden's running mate
kamala harris clearly adds some
excitement to the ticket
chris wallace is the host of fox news
sunday i i do think
in general the enthusiasm issue is
overplayed
when you ask uh trump and biden
supporters are you enthusiastic for the
person you support
trump vastly beats
biden in terms of people who are
enthusiastic about the person they're
voting for
but when you ask them how strongly do
you feel about the person you're
opposing
biden vastly beats trump in other words
there's tremendous anti-trump feeling
among
biden supporters and in the end i'm not
sure it matters if you're
enthusiastically going to the polls
to vote for one candidate or against
another they still count as votes
well i guess you know another question
is is dislike of the president
enough to get the democrats over the
finish line
if that's the main motivator absolutely
i'm not saying it will be
but do i think that particularly when it
when a
candidate is the incumbent and running
for re-election
the the choice is often a referendum
it's less about
you know trump versus clinton when
they're both running for the same office
and neither holds it
uh to a certain degree this is going to
be a referendum on donald trump
how did he handle the coronavirus how
did he handle the economy
and you know if people think that he
hasn't handled it well and they have
some
uh belief in some modicum of belief
in that that biden and harris would do a
better job that can be enough to get him
elected i'm not saying it will be but it
could be
a weekly unemployment came claims
finally came in
under a million for the first time in
five months
but the us also just had the highest
number
of coronavirus deaths in a single day
since may so it does it feels still like
a real
uphill battle and the longer that goes
on
it can't be good for the president right
absolutely
um well look i don't think people are
going to blame
the president for the virus of one of
the
shots that kamala harris took on
wednesday against the president
he inherited the longest economic
expansion
in history from barack obama and joe
biden and then like everything else he
inherited
he ran it straight into the ground you
know the president didn't drive the
economy into the ground
if the virus did having said that people
are going to make a judgment
given this this horrible thing that was
not the president's fault
has he handled it well or has he handled
it badly and
there's no reason to believe i
understand the number of cases are down
from their high point and in some of the
hot spots like florida and texas and
arizona
but there's no reason to believe that
that we're done with the virus or that
we're even close to being done with the
virus and
if it can continue to flare up in places
at various points and i think school
is a real you know trouble spot i can
understand the arguments for going
sending kids back to school i can
understand also the concerns about
sending kids back to school you could
get a flare up of the
of the virus again and that could have
an impact on the on the economy as it
has since march
and democrats seem to be trying to
um make the leap if you will and say
if his handling of the pandemic had been
better
than the economic hit wouldn't have been
so bad
so like blaming him from that standpoint
i i think that's an argument you can
make i mean
i think the argument would be that we
haven't had a national plan and had
there been
more uh of whether it can be imposed
legally or whether it's simply the bully
pulpit of the president
if he had set some markers earlier i
mean i remember the day
i forget whether it was in march or
april when the
the cdc i think was in april first came
out and said we think everybody should
wear masks
and the first words out of the
president's mouth were i'm not going to
wear a mask and at a certain point it
almost became a sign of
of being uh too far to the left or
politically correct to wear a mask
something the president doesn't say
anymore i think you can argue that
that had we pushed for some of the
restrictions for instance that we had in
new york where
you know the virus is very much uh down
i mean it's one of the best
places in the country in terms of of the
virus they went through a terrible time
but they really cracked down on it
you know had we not opened too soon in
some places maybe
the virus would be under more control
and therefore the economic impact would
not have been a steve
what about the fight over another relief
package the way those talks
stalled and the blame game is one side
more
in danger with voters than the other for
that
i don't know but as far as i'm concerned
lisa i
i you know it's sort of for me it's a
box on both their houses
i mean here's a case where the country
is in such desperate shape you've got
millions of people
who are unemployed they've now lost the
the
600 benefit and there's some question as
to
whether they're going to get a 300
benefit and if so how soon
uh small businesses the ppp the payroll
protection
program money has run out uh eviction
protections have run out
you've got millions of people who are
really going to suffer because of this
and you know i'm less interested in in
you know is it more the democrats fault
or
more the republicans fault but wouldn't
you think that somewhere between a
trillion dollars which is what the
republicans are offering
and three trillion which is what the
democrats want
wouldn't you think that somewhere in
between one and three trillion dollars
you could arrive at some figure that
would help people in trouble
and and you know be the half loaf
more than the republicans want less than
the democrats want so i frankly i blame
i blame them all i think i think it
really stinks
you know the president went on fox
business thursday morning and he
actually
blamed the stalemate at least in part on
the democrats wanting billions of
dollars
for mail-in voting and the post office
now they need that money in order to
have the post office work so it can take
all of these millions and millions of
ballots
a lot of voters are scared though i mean
could his continued
criticism of that backfire
potentially it's one of the concerns i
know that republicans in the states have
that if you keep saying there's a
problem with mail-in voting and you
shouldn't mail and vote
the democrats will mail and vote and
republicans won't and you know it'll
become
a self-fulfilling prophecy in some of
these states not just
in the presidential race but also in
state races
uh i think there there is a real danger
of that and
i don't know that that's really you know
when you think of what we're talking
about here a trillion dollars or three
trillion dollars
the kind of money that they're talking
about for mail-in voting
and more money for the post office i
think it's like 25 or 30
billion which is a lot of money but not
in the context of
two or three trillion you know
one of the much bigger issues is aid to
cities and states where
uh republicans want it to be a 150
billion
and democrats want 900 billion that that
is a much bigger issue
the president keeps calling attention to
to the violent protests and the looting
still happening in some cities around
the country
most often cities with democratic mayors
he's quick to note
and he's he's even saying look you'll
get more of this now if you
elect biden and harris even as he
seems to be trying to keep more focus on
the virus at the same time
this becoming you know a competing
narrative at this point
no i i mean i think that it's a a
perfectly
legitimate issue for the president to
bring up and uh and a concern
people you know people want to see
things running well
and to the degree that that they're not
seeing it in
in the virus or the economy and maybe
they blame that more on republicans than
democrats
but on the other hand they look at the
disorder in the streets
and blame that on democrats more than
republicans i think that's a fair
subject for the president to bring up
i know some of the protesters when when
people start looting in some of these
cities like portland say hey you're just
helping trump
doing it you know those those that video
every morning
on the news here's what happened
overnight in portland or seattle or
chicago or new york
it upsets and energizes a lot of people
and you could understand obviously
the trump base but even perhaps some
swim cutters will say
well man i don't want to have that going
on in cities and
you know i'm not sure how fair it is to
tie it to biden or kamala harris but
you know it i think it's a perfectly
legitimate issue for republicans to
bring up
i don't know if he's going to settle on
one nickname for kamala harris
a lot of adjectives have come from the
president and his campaign so far
phony nasty mean do you think
nicknames will be effective this time
around
well i i don't know that it changes any
minds
you know the trump base is pretty strong
and they will love it
uh and uh you know but i mean it's a
little bit
i think in politics you have to there's
a little bit of leeway it's like kamala
harris saying
that that the president drove the
economy into the ground when obviously
the virus that drove the economy into
the ground um
but you know the nicknames help i the
one that i think
and i don't know whether voters are
going to care about it but i do think
that you know looking and becoming a
little bit more
of a student of uh harris's record
you know there were certainly
inconsistencies and she was more
moderate more mainstream as as the
attorney general
in california and then when she came to
washington as a senator and started uh
running for president almost immediately
she moved to the left there's no
question about that because that's what
the
balance of power in the democratic party
is now and you can see some
some flips on decisions you could see
some flips on decisions
even during the campaign like medicare
for all so i think that's something
that we're going to have to explore you
know her her
candidacy is for the vice presidency is
only two days old but as people dig into
that record
they're gonna find some stuff chris
wallace host of fox news sunday don't
miss it
and uh thank you very much chris for
your time you bet thank you lisa
[Music]
[Applause]
from the fox news podcasts network
subscribe and listen to the trey gowdy
podcast
former federal prosecutor and four-term
u.s congressman from south carolina
brings you a one-of-a-kind podcast
subscribe and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcasts.com
rate and review the fox news rundown on
apple podcasts or wherever you listen
and now some good news with tanya j
powers
this week's good news comes from a
church in new orleans
the folks at the redeemer presbyterian
church have gone viral for their
sanctuary social distancing reminders
in order to keep people a safe space
apart during the pandemic
church officials taped signs to some of
the wooden pews
to make sure parishioners knew they
shouldn't sit there
and instead of saying reserved or don't
sit here they got creative
they added some humor mixed in with some
faith teaching and the results are
unforgettable
printed on a sheet of paper held to the
end of the pew with blue tape
are signs that reference scripture like
i have prepared a place for you
then underneath those words it says just
not this pew
another says jesus set the five thousand
down in rose
just not in this one zacchaeus climbed a
sycamore tree to get a better view
this pew was not it you will find me
when you seek me
just not in this pew keep seeking and
abraham was a hundred years old when
isaac was born
and if he were here today he still
wouldn't be allowed to sit in this pew
a post about the silly signs on the
church's facebook page has had more than
4 500 likes
church officials say some of the quips
were borrowed from others and some are
originals
and they help in their effort to keep
attendance under 100
instead of the 1000 they could
accommodate the pandemic also means
masks are worn during services and
there's less singing
like many churches redeemer live streams
its services and posts video online for
those who are staying home
and told wdsu tv that they are quote
glad we are not alone in this journey
tonya j powers fox news
it's time for your fox news commentary
guy benson
what's on your mind following roughly
two consecutive months of nightly riots
in portland oregon
city and state officials uniformly
democrats
place blame on the trump administration
and federal law enforcement officers
operating in the city
that presence was largely concentrated
around protecting a federal courthouse
that antifa members and rioters had been
attempting to burn down
for weeks an agreement was worked out
for the feds to withdraw
and reduce their presence with local and
state officials stepping up
that should stop the chaos right wrong
the riots have continued
they've been disruptive and violent with
agitators attempting to set
fire to police precincts even the
left-wing mayor called this attempted
murder
[Applause]
threats and intimidation this is not
about black lives matter this is not
about social justice or reform
it's violent agitation and it's
unacceptable
this is guy benson host of the guy
benson show
[Music]
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com
and for up to the minute news go to
foxnews.com
[Music]
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust
and click the fox news rundown playlist
for the latest episodes